وقبل ساعات من انطلاق اعمال القمه
اليابانيه الكوريه الجنوبيه اطلقت كوريا
الشماليه صاروخا باليستيا في الساعات
الاولى من صباح اليوم سقط في البحر بين
شبه الجزيره الكوريه واليابان ورجحت وزاره
الدفاع اليابانيه ان يكون الصاروخ باليسيا
عابرا للقارات وقالت انه حلق على ارتفاع
6000 كيلومتر وقطع مسافه 1000 كلم
هذا وتضمنت التجارب كوريا الشماليه
الصواريخ الباليستيه وصواريخ كروز واخرى
تفوق سرعه الصوت مرات اعده لكن في الفتره
الاخيره
ركزت كوريا الشماليه في تجاربها على
الصواريخ الباليستيه العابره للقارات من
فئه هو سونج ومن ابرزها صاروخ هوسونغ 14
الذي يبلغ مداه نحو 10,000 كلم ويمكنه
اصابه اجزاء من الولايات المتحده ولكن لا
يمكنه الوصول الى الساحلي الشرقي وفي
فبراير شباط الماضي اطلقت بيون بيانغ
الصاروخ هو سونج 15 الذي يقدر مداه ب 14
الف كيلو متر في تدريب يهدف الى ضمان قوه
الرضع النوويه للبلاد وضمن الصواريخ
الباليستيه المتوسطه المدى طورت كوريا
الشماليه الصاروخ هو سونج اثنا عشر
ليكون محمولا على مركبات متحركه وزودته
براس الحربي واحد وزنه 500 كلغ هذا وقد
تزامنت التجربه الصاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه
مع مناورات مشتركه بين الجيشين الكوري
الجنوبي والامريكي وهذه هي اكبر مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه منذ خمس سنوات وقال الجيش
الكوري الجنوبي ان المناورات الدفاعيه
وتتضمن تدريبات في زمن الحرب لصد هجمات
محتمله من كوريا الشماليه